grab your tickets to ocean land and use
your baby as a weapon because we have
the first super hero show with flying
sexes
yes it's Amazon's latest original the
boys and I was blown away this show is
badass that was diabolical so in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the ending and some of the things you
may have missed along the way get ready
because here we go the last episode is
titled you found me and it's no wonder
the writers called it this considering
almost every character in this episode
is searching for someone
whether it be Hugh for starlight in the
church Hugh for Frenchie and mother's
milk in captivity Billy for Stillwell or
the biggest shocker of them all Billy
who is finally reunited with his wife
Becca only to find out she is raising
home Landers son but we'll get into that
in a bit let's travel halfway around the
world to tell riff at Syria where
homeland er takes down a terrorists
chemical manufacturing lab of course
this is all a setup if the terrorists
are found to be in possession of
compound V a chemical that can turn
people into superheroes aka Supes as
well as acting as a steroid for current
Supes
the US government will need some extra
firepower to combat this new threat and
that's what Madeleine Stilwell has in
mind it is a whole new world now and
there is only one company that has the
product to fight back Madeline's goal
throughout the season was to get the US
government to allow Supes into the
military giving Vaught the company which
owns these soups essentially billions in
contract deals and Madeline isn't afraid
to do anything to get what she wants she
blackmails a u.s. senator and
orchestrate several devious plots all of
this for what Madeline wants more than
anything else to be the head of vaud in
the final episode she's approached by
the mysterious mr. Edgar who up until
this point we've only heard of he's the
head of Vaught and is pleased with her
work setting her up to be the head of
the company when he retires
but Madeline's want is tied into making
but the most profitable company that it
can be not about superheroes protecting
its citizens with honor and integrity as
we learn early on in the show the
superheroes are
treated as brands marketed to sell
commercials movies and products their
crime solving is entirely orchestrated
by Vaught where they simply need to show
up beat up the bad guy and wait for the
cameras to Rye for their cheesy sound
bites
yes paint over him and say this is lit
additionally the more d-list superheroes
are given contracts to protect
individual cities like when the mayor of
Baltimore comes to Madeline and she
offers Nubian Prince for the sum of 300
million dollars with the latest news
that terrorists now have their own
superhero the Department of Justice
makes a deal with Madeline to acquire
her soups in the war on terror up until
this point soups were only allowed to
engage in national non military affairs
part of the steel also includes making
the boys wanted men which leads to the
arrest of Frenchie Kimiko and Mother's
Milk
Starlite however is struggling with
something different this episode all her
life she was told by her mother that her
powers were a gift from God that she was
chosen she gave away her entire
childhood for the dream of being in the
7 which didn't turn out the way she had
hoped for but when she finds out she
wasn't chosen by God but rather sold to
bought and turned into his soup it
doesn't go over so well my own dreams
star lights entire life was built on a
lie and to further add to the pain she
finds out her father left because of
this decision he couldn't live with the
guilt of seeing his daughter as some lab
rat just so he could pay off his debts
we also have the deep who has been sent
off to Ohio after he got hashtag me to
buy starlight he learns that he won't be
leaving Ohio anytime soon saddened that
he won't get to command his own naval
Marine unit his character gets his
comeuppance this season after he
sexually assaulted starlight when he
himself is sexually assaulted without
his consent by an eager fan in episode 7
who violates his gills regardless the
deep is likely to hold resentment
towards Vaught priming him to switch
allegiances next season and seek
Redemption Billy and Hugh seek out grace
Mallory the original founder of the boys
a group dedicated to exposing the
savate and the soups like billion hue
grace lost to people close to her at the
hands of Supes her two grandchildren who
were burned to death by Lamplighter the
soup who was part of the seven but
retired in Episode one making room for
starlight vengeance is arguably the
biggest theme of season one Hugh lost
his girlfriend Robin and Billy seeks
vengeance for the disappearance of his
wife
eight years ago homeland er raped his
wife and Becca was never seen from again
Billy believes so much that she's still
alive that when he finds out his
sister-in-law made a grave for her he
demolishes the tombstone in defiance
grace says she won't help them she's
learned that vengeance isn't the
solution vengeance isn't a path to glory
Hugh it's a one-way ticket to a dead end
and Hugh in his final confrontation with
Billy learns this - this is never gonna
stop it's just gonna be more blood and
awfulness this completes Hugh's
character art for the season if you
recall he starts off as a timid pushover
hey Gary okay unable to fight back and
even his girlfriend had to first ask him
out I had to ask you with the death of
Robin he is purely motivated by
vengeance to avenge his girlfriend and
take down a train and any soups that get
in his way you'll teach me to outrun
cancer contrast this to the hue we see
at the end he's not a pushover he stands
up to billion in the biggest ironic
twist goes from wanting to kill a train
to performing CPR on him to save his
life his character has learned that
vengeance isn't the answer
this positive transformation is rewarded
when he's later saved by starlight
opening up potential for the two of them
to reunite in season two Billy on the
other hand does not change like Hugh did
his hatred for homeland er runs so deep
he will do anything and everything to
get at him but how do you take down an
indestructible superhero as Queen Maeve
points out to starlight in Episode seven
our weakness is the same as anyone's its
people
people we care about if you want to get
at home Lander get at the people he
loves you know the only thing he gives
two shits about yes Madeline and home
Landers relationship is well awkward
home Lander never grew up with a family
especially a mother the closest thing he
had to a father was dr. Vogel bomb when
he was raised in a lab so home Lander
manifested this desire for a mother's
love over years and years this
manifestation causes him to become
infatuated with her and desire her
approval
he often uses his x-ray vision to peep
into her room while she's using the
breast pump something Madeleine knows
he's doing by watching the security
camera and she uses this to her
advantage almost every time homeland
refuses to do something whether it be a
press junket or video skit Madeleine
uses a combination of motherly love and
sexuality to bend home blender like a
piece of clay in her hand the strongest
person in the worlds that comes to
laying on her lap and later as we'll
find out climaxing in 10 seconds when
they eventually do the deed she is his
weakness his kryptonite Billie exploits
this by holding Madelyn hostage and when
home Lander arrives home Lander taunts
Billy asking if he knows with a hundred
percent truth that Becca is dead because
you see here home Lander already knows
the truth that Becca is alive earlier in
the episode when homeland er asks
Madelyn to tell nothing but the truth
she tells him that Becca who was holding
his child died while having a
miscarriage this doesn't sit right with
homeland er what we don't see is that
homeland er went back to dr. Vogel bombs
I went back to focal bomb and I managed
to squeeze the truth out of him he then
whispers into her ear something we the
viewer can't even make out he's telling
Madelyn that Becca and his boy are still
alive that he knows the truth Madelyn
apologizes but this betrayal is too
biting for homeland er who uses his
laser eyes to burn a hole through her
head this leaves us with Billy and
homeland er with his plan totally gone
to [ __ ] he blows the explosives only to
wake up hours late
on a random lawn somewhere in the
suburbs home Lander saved him from the
blast but why he knows that for Billy a
fate worse than death is to see that his
wife had left him and has been raising
the son of the man he's hated more than
anything
Billy's path for vengeance has put him
in his own personal hell when I'm super
excited to see him navigate in season
two but what the hell was Becca doing
all these years why did she just
disappear and not tell Billy well for
one I think we can rule out it's because
she didn't love him and just wanted to
get away from the flashbacks we saw this
season the two are totally in love and
their relationship is strong so
obviously some outside force is at play
here we also know that home lander until
a few hours ago also did not know about
Becca and the boy my best guess is that
this was a plan by dr. Vogel bomb to
make amends for the experiments he did
on children as he tells home Lander in
episode 7 you should have been raised in
a home with a family who loved you not
in a cold lab with doctors dr. Vogel
bomb doesn't want this new kid to go
through the same thing home Lander did
he facilitated Becca's escape but in
order to keep Becca and the boys safe
they would need to keep everything
secret meaning Becca would have to stay
away from Billy in exchange for the
safety of her son now what would be even
more interesting is if Madeline didn't
know about this either and that this
whole time she thought she was telling
the truth and homeland or killed her for
no reason that would have huge
ramifications for his character in
season 2 potentially pitting him against
fought industries should the writers
choose to go in that direction with
Malin now gone does this mean we'll see
more of Gustavo Frank I mean mr. Edgar
in season 2 I think so the actor who
plays him usually doesn't do small one
scene roles anymore unless it can launch
into something much bigger and with
season two already confirmed it's likely
he'll be the next big villain we also
have the rise of terrorists oops
and the fact thought now has the soups
in the military bought is poised to be
much more powerful and taking them down
will be much more difficult season 2
will likely see some of the seven
switching allegiances the two most
likely to change are a train and Queen
Maeve a train because he'll learn the
boy
are simply trying to expose Vaught and
its diabolical plans surrounding
compound v a compound he himself is
addicted to and causes his heart attack
and Queen Maeve because she's watched as
Vaught and homeland er manipulate the
masses for their own political gain how
can we forget the chilling plain scene
in which she pleads with homeland er to
save the children but he won't because
he doesn't want witnesses the writers
are really setting her up to make a
switch in season 2 but I want to hear
your opinions on the boys it's been one
of my favorite superhero shows in a long
time which actually had characters who I
cared about leave a comment below make
sure to LIKE and subscribe because I
have more videos on the way and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much